Welcome to ICT for Dummies Episode 8
Premium and discount
Buy low and sell high
Yeah, keep it short in there
Add to premium
And keep longin' at the discount
Cause this is
Buying low
And sell high
If it would not, she won't get you right
Find six liquidity and rebalance ranges
That's how you trade this
With the premium and discount
You will maybe probably get laid
What? That's a crazy last one
Alright everyone, so today for this video we're going to be going over premium and discount
We're going to be going over what these ranges actually mean
I'm sure you've heard the term used a lot inside of a premium range or inside of a discount range
So we'll get into how you can actually use them
It might be a little bit confusing cause there's going to be a lot of different ranges
But we're going to get into some examples and again show you how to actually use them
The first step is whipping out your fib retracement tool
This is going to be your best friend when it comes to marking out premium and discount
Blake, show them what that looks like
Oh, they actually did bring my
Your nutsack ointment
My nutsack ointment is here, be right back
So first things first guys, I just want to explain to you guys why this is actually important, premium and discount
And just give you an analogy for like real life
For example, when you're at the store and you want to buy something, right
You want to buy it at a discount
For example, for PD Premium, you want to be getting it on those sales, right
When we have 25% off for National Woman's Day for celebrating Patrick, right
So you want to be getting it during times like that
You do not want to be getting it at a premium when prices are inflated or when prices are raised
No, no, no, don't join the Discord at a discount
That's when we get all you damn brain rotters who just don't even care to learn
All you care about is just
Some of you guys just like sometimes just fricking join the Discord
And just like signal, signal
And you don't even care about my feelings
I'm there to teach you, bro
I just want to change your life and stuff
All you care about is like yo, PB, when's the next discount
Not everything's about a discount
They always ask when the next signal is coming out
But never how's the signaler
How's the signaler doing
I mean again guys, for example, you're in the store
You want to be buying eggs when they're on a discount
Not when it's premium, not when the prices are inflated
That's essentially the whole reasoning behind premium and discount, right
You want to be getting in on the market at a good price
So with this lesson, we're really going to show you how to utilize the Fibonacci tool as effectively as possible
And what this is going to do is going to optimize your entries
If you're longing from a premium or you're shorting from a discount
It's not going to be as optimal as if you're longing from the discount or shorting from the premium
So let's show you guys where actually premium and discount lies
So for example, in this trading leg, we have a very obvious impulsive swing high and a swing low
And let's say in this scenario that we are bearish
We're going to be drawing out our Fib tool from the swing high all the way down here towards this swing low
Now really quick, if you guys want to just look at the Fib retracement
I just have 0.5 here and 1
Now if I want to be shorting, I want to see price trade into equilibrium of this range
This is called equilibrium
The 0.5 is called equilibrium
In this bearish scenario, anything here is considered discount
Anything here is considered premium, right?
So if we're shorting, we want to be in premium
Now, like we've said before, and we say this all the time
Price is always doing one of two things
What is that? It is either seeking liquidity or rebalancing ranges
So like Blake mentioned, when you do have these super impulsive moves
For example, this very strong bearish order flow that leaves little to no retracement
If you want to short, you at least want to see a rebalance of this range before you take shorts lower
You want to be shorting from the premium of this range
You want to be shorting once equilibrium has been hit and that range has been rebalanced
And the main point of premium and discount, guys, all comes down to risk to reward
So if I bring out my risk to reward tool, you can see here at exactly equilibrium
This will give me a one-to-one risk to reward from the buy side liquidity to the sell side liquidity
And as we get deeper into the premium of this range, the better my risk to reward will be
And as you see, as we keep going deeper into this range, the better my risk to reward becomes
So this is going to be really helpful for you guys to actually get better risk to reward on your trades
Because you do not want to be shorting, for example, here when price hasn't even reached equilibrium of this range
Because your risk to reward will be negative and that is not good
So now we can mark out this bullish leg bottom to top
And as you can see here, we now have the premium and the discount marked out, right?
So if you want to take longs, ideally, this is not the area we want to be longing in
Why? Because we are very premiumed right now
You would want to see price rebalance this range, which means at least trade up until equilibrium
And now this imbalance has been corrected and now longs are going to be far more optimal
And you're going to get better risk to reward because we are discounted now
So obviously, if you're longing near equilibrium, you're going to get at least a one-to-one back to this high
And like Blake said, you know, the deeper you go into this range, into the discount for longs
The better that your risk to reward is going to be
I'll say it a million times, all these concepts and everything we teach you, you don't just use them individually
You pair them with everything else we've taught you
But this is very important to know because this is going to optimize your entries
It's going to optimize your RR, it's going to help you avoid getting stop rated
And it's going to allow you to achieve more consistent trading results
So let's pair this with something like fair value gaps, right?
If we want to be longing a fair value gap of this bullish leg
Ideally, we wouldn't want to long the one that's premiumed all the way here
Because we're obviously not going to get good risk reward
And chances are that price won't reject this premium bullish value gap
Like it will reject this discounted bullish value gap
Why is that? Because if you're going to be longing this fair value gap up here, this range has still yet to be rebalanced
Ideally, you'd want to wait for the range to get rebalanced
If you're going to enter off a fair value gap, you'd want it to be the discounted one if you're going to enter long
So this is going to have a way higher probability of actually being respected and then trading to the desired level
Now again, guys, this might get a little bit confusing because obviously there's going to be ranges inside of ranges
For example, here we have this dealing range that we just had
But then also, once this swing gets made, we're going to be having another dealing range right here
So we're going to get into some examples on how to actually draw out your ranges correctly
So you don't just get lost because this is a very confusing ICT concept that I feel like a lot of people get mixed up with
Like where do I draw our ranges?
But we're going to go into some examples right now to hopefully clear things up
So again, guys, with this concept, you want to be utilizing it with other confluences, right?
So as we talked about in our liquidity video, right?
We had a sweep here of this liquidity right here
Nice little sell side sweep
Yes. What do we notice we got above guys?
Some nice buy side liquidity
We have buy side liquidity resting here
And we also have that low resistance liquidity as a liquidity pool
So obviously once we've identified that we have that sell side sweep on the higher time frame and we swept that 15 minute low
Now we have this impulse leg on the one minute time frame, right?
We clearly have very strong bullish reaction here after that sell side sweep
And now we can mark out this range top to bottom, right?
So here we have equilibrium resting, which is going to be the point five
So ideally I'd want to be longing from a retracement into at least equilibrium
But something I do want to say is that we don't necessarily need to be in the trade at discount
As long as we know that this range has been rebalanced, we should be okay to be longing
So if you're feeling confident enough with price where you're telling yourself, okay, this range has been rebalanced
I have all the bullish conflicts that I need to be longing and we're in this discount
This range has gone rebalanced as well. You know, this is looking good for longs
I'll enter off here
But sometimes you might want to wait for a little bit of structure
So you'll probably wait for a reaction off of equilibrium
And maybe once you get that reaction, you're like, okay, I'll take longs from here
Stop, I'll have to swing low and then I'll target all this, right?
So what I'm trying to get out here is you don't necessarily need to be in the trade at discount
But you do want to see that range get rebalanced before you enter long
But before price truly enters bullish order flow, you're going to notice that it's going to want to rebalance this range
Which you can see right here. It taps into equilibrium
It hits this discounted fair value gap. And then what happens after we get that delivery higher, right?
And we go ahead and run all these levels that we have marked out
So this is why understanding how to use this fit retracement tool is really important
Because if you are able to mark out premiums and discounts of legs, then you're going to optimize your entry
But before we even go about executing on the lower time frame, we also still want to be analyzing if these ranges are being rebalanced on the higher time frame
So right now we're on the five minute chart. We were previously on the one minute chart
If we mark out this leg right here on the five minute chart, you can clearly see that price goes ahead trades higher really impulsively
And then before it continues higher and breaks its high once again, what do we get?
We get that rebalanced equilibrium
Why is this important? Because it's the same things that you want to see on the lower time frame
You want to see in the higher time frame same things you want to see on the higher time frame
You want to see in the lower time frame. It's all fractal. You want to be able to apply it across all time frames
So if you're seeing a range get rebalanced on the higher time frame, what's it going to help you do?
It's going to help you determine your bias. It's going to help you go about your next strong liquidity
And you can see this is literally constantly happening. We get this strong move up price rebalances hits equilibrium goes up higher
What do we get here? Price moves up rebalance this range goes up higher. Do you get what I'm trying to say now?
There's always going to be a stronger reaction when price is rebalancing these ranges and tapping into these significant PDR race
So hopefully you guys see what I'm trying to get at here, right?
Price usually needs to rebalance these ranges before it can continue in the direction that it wants to
So now that we know that the higher time frame leg is rebalanced, we don't really have to worry about price trading lower here
We just want to pair these exact same confluences on the lower time frame so we can execute properly
So we know the higher time from got rebalanced, right?
We trade it into equilibrium and then we also get that trade back into equilibrium here and everything is aligning
We're clearly seeing that every time we have a leg up price goes back
Rebalances that range and then gets a reaction and we know from here we are ready for longs, baby
And with this guys also is that ranges are always expanding, right?
So every time we take out a new swing your range is constantly expanding
So for example here we have this swing low and then this major swing high point
And what you should be looking for underneath equilibrium of this range is liquidity pools or fair value gaps
And in this scenario here we have both
We have this liquidity pool being the south side liquidity and then we have this bullish fair value gap
And that's how we were able to come to that conclusion of that bullish bias on the higher time frame because we expanded this range
And we saw that price traded below equilibrium of this range and then we got our lower time frame entry
Now we're going to get into a bearish example of premium discount. Good one
Alright guys, so right here we have a very strong impulsive down move
And this was probably from news, right? So we can mark out the swing high
This is our swing high and then this is our swing low
And this does go lower and as I was saying ranges are always expanding
So you just draw it out a little bit lower now
Now that that swing low is put in place
We want to see price trade into premium of this range before entering into any sort of shorts, right?
We want to see price get rebalanced and then we want to see that lower time frame confirmation get out of this to then enter a short
So I'm going to go down now to the five minute
So as you guys can see here, we have this bearish five minute for value gap sitting at equilibrium of this range, right?
So I want to see this get traded to before entering into a short
You do not want to be shorting, you know, when we're down here before hitting equilibrium, right?
Because there's still room for price to move
We still need price to trade into equilibrium orders are getting filled here, right?
Nobody in the market is entering at this low into discount, right?
So once price trades into this five minute for value gap
I'm then going to look for that lower time frame structure to get confirmation that we're going to go lower towards this sell side liquidity down here
And from here price ends up trading back down towards the sell side liquidity as you can see
And I want you guys to know also to not be marking out every single range that you guys see, right?
For example here in this scenario, if I'm going to be bearish, right?
And I'm looking for shorts down towards this sell side liquidity
I'm not going to be marking out, you know, impulse legs from here to here, right?
Because that's not what I'm looking to see price get traded into
I'm not looking for longs, right? I'm looking for shorts
So all I'm caring about is this impulse like here
And then if I'm going to be dropping down to the lower time frame, right?
I'm going to be looking for those impulse legs on the lower time frame
So we're going to get into a couple more examples now guys, just instill this into your brain
So here we've identified another super strong impulsive leg down, right?
We have this very, very blatantly voluminous, juicy, ginormous fricking...
Hey yo!
Okay, we know that now since there's a huge imbalance in price
It most likely needs to be corrected if it is going to sell off again, right?
But like we said before, ranges can be confusing
And just because we hit equilibrium of this doesn't mean that order flow has to flip completely bearish
We can always continue to analyze the ranges as we go to see where price truly wants to go
So if we play this out, we see that price trades up until equilibrium
And naturally we do get a reaction
But instead of expanding lower, we can see that price actually ends up respecting this newly formed range and continues higher
And notice what price keeps doing, right?
If we continue focusing on these new ranges and these new impulse legs being created
Which are now towards the upside and we keep marking them out
What do we realize?
Well, we notice that price will continue rebalancing these and then expanding higher
So we do have a flip in order flow here
This range itself is getting ran through
But at first we did get a reaction from the equilibrium
However, with these new ranges being formed, we are now getting reactions to the upside
And these bullish ranges are getting rebalanced and continuing to expand higher
And this happens nearly all the time, right?
Sometimes it's not perfect
But for the most part, you are getting these rebalances pretty frequently before price continues to expand higher
So yeah guys, I know this might seem like a little bit confusing now
But guys, trust me, once you start adding this with all of your other confluence like we've taught you
Like liquidity sweeps, like for value gaps, right?
We're going to get into daily bias and all of that later on
But you guys will slowly start piecing together all of these concepts that we teach you
And it will make a lot more sense later on
So if we use something like the fib tool and premiums and discounts
And just a simple understanding that ranges naturally need to get rebalanced almost all the time to continue in the corresponding direction
Then you can use that to help you determine something like your bias, right?
So let's say we mark out this leg top to bottom
We have this really strong leg, this impulsive bearish leg
And we're trading AM session
Then we're most likely thinking that for AM session we'd want to see price rebalance this range
So maybe during AM session we're going to be looking for longs
We're going to have a bullish bias because we know there's a huge imbalance in this leg
And it most likely needs to be corrected
You can mark something out like this hourly bearish fair value gap
You can anticipate, okay, going into this morning
I probably want to see if I can catch some longs
Maybe trade up into this hourly bearish fair value gap that's sitting at the premium of the range
And so obviously you can see during AM session that's exactly what you get
Price goes ahead, rebalances this range
And now if you're trading PM session
You can use that higher time from analysis with premiums and discounts to also determine your next bias and your next draw on liquidity
So now you know, okay, we're sitting inside this hourly bearish fair value gap
It's PM session now
This range has already been rebalanced
Do I really want to keep looking for longs?
Most likely not
And you can see that PM session goes ahead and has a strong reaction down because we rebalance this range
So this is like very vaguely just showing you how you can use this to help determine your bias
Simply analyzing where these imbalances in price are lying
Whether we are trading in the premium or discount
And this will help you get a more accurate narrative of price in general
So we can almost piece this in like three parts, right?
You have like your higher timeframe leg
We have this really strong bullish leg
If we're going to be bullish going into the morning
Then we want to make sure this range is rebalanced
Awesome
We know that we have this higher timeframe leg being rebalanced
Let's consider the green zone to be like the hourly timeframe
Maybe the one hour, the four hour
We know that this higher timeframe leg has gotten rebalanced
And we know that we're getting a reaction from it
So then if we're like looking at relatively lower timeframes
Like the 15 minute, let's make this like orange
Then this is most likely the current trading range that we're in of the session
And we'd also want to see this get rebalanced
And this get respected
If we want to have more confirmation for a bullish bias
So we sort of start off on the higher timeframe
When we drop down and continue receiving that confirmation from price action
We know that this higher timeframe hourly leg has gotten rebalanced and respected
We get a reaction
Now if we're looking at like a 15 minute chart
We know that this range has also gotten rebalanced and respected
And now if we go down all the way to like where we're executing
Which is mainly going to be on the one to five minute timeframe
With the way Blake and I trade
We'll mark this out as yellow
Then we can get our final confirmation to see if these lower, lower timeframe ranges are also getting rebalanced
You know, we're probably looking for an entry now
So we'll have like a bullish value gap sitting right here
And we want to see, you know, maybe this range got rebalanced
Trade into a bullish value gap, respect that
And from there, we're locked in for longs
And we can anticipate that price will run higher
So I know this looks pretty sloppy and it's like all jumbled up together
But you get what I'm trying to say, right?
You always want to keep dropping down into the timeframes
Making sure that everything is truly being respected and building up that confirmation
The more confirmation you can build across each timeframe
The higher probability that your trade is going to play out
Okay guys, so going off what Patrick just said
I'm going to be pairing everything together in an example right here on the chart
So on the higher timeframe, I'm bullish
So I'm going to be marking out this swing low here to this swing high, right?
And underneath that, what do we see?
We have a bullish fair value gap here on the hourly timeframe
So for me to be taking longs, what I want to see price do
Is for price to trade back into this bullish fair value gap
Get some reaction out of that
Maybe form that lower timeframe confirmation
And then we can get some longs out of there to target this buy-side liquidity
So now I'm going to drop down into the 15-minute timeframe
And I'm going to wait for this fair value gap to get traded into
So once this fair value gap gets traded into and we respect it
I'm now on the 15-minute timeframe
I'm going to wait for that structure to then validate this bias
I'm going to go down now to this 5-minute timeframe
To see if we can actually get an entry and if we can get some reaction off of this level
So now I'm going to whip out this Fib
I'm going to go from the swing low to the swing high
And I'm going to wait for price to trade into equilibrium
Into this fair value gap to then get a trade idea off this
I keep expanding this range here, keep expanding this
Now that the swing high is put into place
I'm looking to see price trade below equilibrium of this range
And what do we see here?
Well, we have sell-side liquidity resting right here
As well as we have this bullish fair value gap right here in discount
So I want to see price then trade lower into this fair value gap
Sweeping out the sell-side liquidity
And then getting along towards this buy-side liquidity above us
Then price ends up sweeping out this low
Trading into this bullish fair value gap
We get a reaction off this
And here I can enter longs with a stop loss of this swing
TP at this high, for example
And maybe you can even leave runners for that buy-side liquidity on the hourly timeframe
And then we can play out price here
And it ends up smacking all of these take profits
So you want to be marking out your Fibonacci guys for everything
On the daily timeframe, on the hourly
To really get a sense of where your bias is
And then for your actual entry point
It's going to be really, really helpful in getting that risk reward
Because the Fibonacci and equilibrium and premium and discount
It's useful for those two reasons
One is for actual imbalances in price
The market likes to trade towards discount
Because that's where a lot of buyers are stepping in
And price likes to trade towards premium
Because that's where a lot of sellers are stepping in
So a lot of orders are getting filled at those areas
And then for us, for traders
We want to be using that as an actual entry point for risk reward reasons
So understanding the two reasons of why the Fib tool
And why premium discount is so helpful
Is going to help you guys a lot in just your overall trading
So yeah guys, that pretty much wraps up premium and discount
You can really apply this to nearly everything in life
So the way you should think about it is if you pull up to a party
And you see a girl that you really like
It's almost like longing at a discount
You want to start, you know, chopping it up with her
Sort of getting in nice before that range gets rebalanced
Before other people start talking
And it's going to allow you to get that optimal entry
Because if you wait like too late into the night
Then chances are that range has already been rebalanced
Someone already talked to her
Someone already got the reps in
And you just missed out on the greatest long opportunity of your life
If you're not taking advice from us
You're probably never going to be rich
Nah, I'm kidding
But seriously, thank you guys so much for watching
ICT for dummies episode 8
Premium and discount
Using Fibonacci
Homework, homework guys
Is going to be mark out your premium and discount ranges
Just go into the chart
Look at the swing highs, look at the swing lows
Mark out your buy side liquidity, mark out that sell side liquidity
And you know, just be marking out your overall ranges
Seeing where price is going to trade towards
Last thing I do want to say
If you are looking for some mentoring from us
We do have applications open for our mentorship right now
You can apply through like our Instagram bio link
We'll probably toss it in the YouTube description too
When you join our mentorship
If you are more like the beginner side
We do give you like a whole 20 course video
Before we get into the live calls
And those videos will essentially explain every single concept that you need
And then we'll get more into like model breakdown
Bias, draw liquidity when the mentorship starts
And there's a lot of really fun interactive
And just great community overall in this mentorship
So if that's something you're interested in
Apply, if that's not something you're interested in
Keep watching this YouTube series
We're going to keep releasing banger videos
We're going to explain really everything for free
And give you all the sauce you need
But for those of you who do want I guess a little bit extra mentoring
Some accountability
And just overall cool community to learn with
Then link in description
Check that out
Make sure to subscribe, like, comment
Tell me what concept you're looking forward to learning most
Drop that comment below
Much love fellas
Peace out